Speaker 1: Let's go to David from Colorado.
David, you're on the air next.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, can.
Speaker 1: You hear me?
I can hear you fine.
Speaker 6: Great.
I wanted to talk quickly about democratic
ideals, given that so many Supreme Court justices
have been appointed by presidents that have
not won the popular vote.
Correct.
Do you support the Supreme Court still as
an institution?
Do you believe it has a rightful place in
our democracy?
Speaker 1: I believe it has a rightful place
in our democracy, but we need to be confident
in it.
And we did a story on the Wednesday show about
how confidence in the Supreme Court has collapsed,
and it's even worse than you're pointing out.
So David correctly points out right now five
of the nine justices were chosen, were nominated
to the court by presidents who lost the popular
vote.
So it was Roberts and Alito by Bush and then
Gorsuch, Coney Barrett and Kavanaugh by Trump.
That's five of the nine justices were chosen
by presidents where more people voted for
their opponents.
But it's even worse than that, David.
In addition to that, one of them quite literally
should have been Barack Obama.
Selection Gorsuch should have actually been
Obama's nomination of Merrick Garland.
Mitch McConnell got in the way of that, but
then it's even worse than that.
Not to really depress you today, David, but
also the completely anti-democratic Senate
where Wyoming gets two senators and California
gets two senators, even though California
has 30 something million people and Wyoming
has not even a million people.
They are the ones who voted to confirm these
people.
So it's a completely anti-democratic process.
And I understand why there is very little
confidence in the court right now, but.
If we could make its makeup more legitimate
as an institution, I do still think that having
a Supreme Court is an important thing.
Speaker 6: Right?
Right.
And I'm totally with you in terms of the antidemocratic
institutions within our system between the
Electoral College and Senate.
I'm actually from Wyoming.
Okay.
Move things to.
Speaker 1: No offense to Wyoming, but listen,
why do you guys have two senators, you know?
Speaker 6: Yeah.
No, it's completely ridiculous.
Yeah, in my opinion.
But do you have any specific reforms in mind?
Something that was talked about during the
2020 campaign by people to judge was a possible
make up in which maybe five justices are appointed
by the conservative nominee, or rather conservative
presidential candidates.
Half or five are nominated by the liberal
presidential candidates, and then the remaining
five are nominated by the ten seated justices.
Do you have anything like that in mind or
any other systems?
Speaker 1: I am open to a lot of reforms.
One idea that is, I think similar to what
you're suggesting, but not exactly it, is
that you always have a54 court and it's just
whoever's in power in the White House gets
the five rather than the four.
That's one idea that I've seen floated term
limits is another.
Obviously, I would love it if the presidents
choosing the justices won the popular vote
and we could actually say they actually were
reflective of the will of the people.
But that requires getting rid of the Electoral
College.
The other aspect to this is there can't be
if you're president, it I think we have to
just set a line.
And even if you have a week left and you nominate
someone, I think that they need to get a confirmation
hearing.
I don't think you can even there it shouldn't
be an option for Mitch McConnell and Republicans
to do what they did.
Speaker 6: No, I totally agree.
Yeah.
Final question on Roe.
Do you think this could be a straw that broke
the camel's back in terms of Democrats winning
back a supermajority?
Speaker 1: We've talked about that.
I don't know yet.
I think that this will probably inspire some
turnout for Democrats in November.
But I don't know about a supermajority.
That seems like a bit of a stretch.
Speaker 6: I totally get that.
Speaker 1: I think not losing would be I think
not losing by as much would be like probably
the best they can do.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
We'll see what happens in November, I suppose.
Absolutely gets it.
Speaker 1: David from Colorado, thank you
so much
for
the call.